all right so let's go to some CNN video
CNN interviewed Trump lawyer Jim trustee
about the leaked audio recording in
which Trump is at Bedminster Golf Club
not at Mar-A-Lago it's summer of 2021
long after Trump has left the White
House and Biden as president and Trump
on the auto audio recording says I have
a classified document here that I can't
show you proving that Trump did not
declassify all of the documents that he
took with him meaning he took classified
documents to which he did not have uh
the right
then we go to CNN last night here's
Caitlin Collins asking Trump's lawyer if
the documents were Declassified As Trump
told us they were why is Trump on the
recording saying I can't show you this
because it's classified very
straightforward and simple question Jim
trusty unable to answer
ask about something you just said to
Abby which was you referenced the fact
that Trump was still president when he
left office he left Washington I think
he about an hour left in his presidency
are you saying that it was in that hour
that he Declassified the documents that
were taken with him now your timing is a
little bit off that he's he landed in
Mar-A-Lago and was at his residence
while still president it was a little
bit after that that Biden was sworn in
so he he had the absolute authority to
take every one of those documents any
document he wants with him when he left
the White House what happens throughout
history through Modern History okay now
he's already he's already being
deceptive
in some hypothetical sense if Trump goes
through the declassification process
while President he would then be able to
make the case that he can take documents
he didn't do that things are not de
facto Declassified because Trump thought
about it or because Trump took them and
Trump admits on the recording that these
are still classified documents meaning
he did not declassify them this guy's
lying and he's being deceptive but if
you take documents and archives thinks
they're entitled to it they start
negotiating and that's what he did he
was telling them things like hey just
ask if you want anything more he gave
them 15 boxes in January of 2022. after
some backup forth but just to be clear
you're making the argument right now by
the time he was on the ground in Florida
after he left Washington that that is
when he Declassified all of these
documents that he took with him no no
I'm saying the documents he brought with
him are effectively
Declassified effectively is doing some
heavy lifting in this sentence and the
problem is lawyers not working for Trump
say that that's not a thing and
personalized under the presidential
record act we're talking about
constitutional Authority Under the
Constitution to declassify if he wants
to take stuff with him and say anything
I take with me is Declassified if he
wants to take stuff and say anything I
read at night is Declassified that was
absolutely his right as president even
if that were the case he didn't do it
and admits the document is classified in
the summer of 2021. and the personal the
presidential records act makes it clear
that we don't even care about classified
information it is a statutory scheme
that if this deals with presidential or
personal only Jim if this was
Declassified then why are we told that
he's on this tape basically telling the
people in the room that he can't share
it with them you are told by doj or FBI
or whoever filtered that to you anything
they can think of to justify all right
so it's all unfair it's all a Witch Hunt
to justify uh indicting Trump here's one
more clip
um uh here's Abby Philip interviewing uh
the same guy Jim trustee and uh it
doesn't really go any better these tapes
would indicate that former president
Trump knew that the documents that he
had were classified yes does that not
make uh his statements about blanket
declassification and some statements by
his Representatives wouldn't that make
those lies yeah I'm not going to dignify
the doj leak what I will tell you is
this when you are because it's extremely
inconvenient to my client is you don't
want to address the substance well it'd
also be nice if you let me answer so let
me just try to answer because he's not
actually trying to answer that's the
thing I am trying to be responsive but
I'm not going to bite on a leak campaign
and try the case in the media what I
will tell you is there is no doubt that
as commander-in-chief and when the
president left Washington DC from
Orlando he was actually still president
when he left for Mar-A-Lago with boxes
of documents that other people packed
for him that he brought at least now
he's admitting there were boxes huh he
was the commander-in-chief there is no
doubt that he has the Constitutional
Authority as commander-in-chief to
declassify it does not have to go
through some sort of bureaucratic
process to be Declassified but wouldn't
it be very easy to Simply prove that he
just Declassified them because even
though he doesn't have to go through a
process right he does have to decide
that it's been done did he tell anyone
yes and and can you prove it sure but
we're not doing it did he declassify
this document that we're referring to
we're not going to try that all right so
as you can see this is a very poor
appearance for Jim trustee one lawyer
wrote to me and said you know these
might be TV lawyer arguments David to
avoid answering the question into
obfuscate these are not arguments any
sensible lawyer would ever make in court
so Trump's going to need something
better than Jim trusts these arguments
if he hopes to to to uh somehow explain
this recording if this actually is
something that leads to charges so again
Espionage being discussed as a possible
situation for Trump we're going to
follow it super closely people often ask
me about my daily routine you know I'm
interviewed about the David Pacman show
how did you do it how do you do this and
like daily routine just often comes up
and how do you stay healthy and of
course I talk about exercise and I talk
about eating the right diet but one of
the things that can happen if you are
not eating the right diet or you're
traveling or life gets in the way is you
end up with some kind of vitamin
deficiency a daily scoop of ag-1 from
our sponsor athletic greens makes this
super easy to take off of your list of
things to worry about one scoop of ag1
you get the entire day's worth of 75
high quality vitamins and minerals from
Whole Food sourced ingredients ag1 is
cheaper than dealing with a bunch of
different supplements it's infinitely
more convenient you just take a scoop
before you have your coffee for example
as I do in the morning and you're
covered for the entire day many of my
friends love ag1
anyone I mention it to seems to get
hooked when I go on vacation I bring the
ag1 travel packs with me especially
because I'm not always eating the same
diet when I'm traveling that I do at
home staying properly nourished so
important to feeling your best ag1 just
makes it really easy and very convenient
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman to get a
free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D so many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below